وقال الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني
نائب رئيس مجلس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه
القطري من الحوار الاستراتيجيه السنويه
بين الدوحه واشنطن منصه مهمه في العلاقات
بين البلدين خلال المؤتمر الصحفي المشترك
مع نظيره الامريكيه اكد وزير الخارجيه
القطريه انه ناقش مع نظيره الامريكي
تطورات الاتفاق النووي الايراني والاوضاع
في العراق وليبيا وافغانستان والقضيه
الفلسطينيه
في تعزيز العلاقات الثنائيه بين البلديه
التي تتمتع همم اسس قويه وصلبه وشراكه
متعدده الاوجه وتعتبر من اهم الشركات
الاستراتيجيه همم لدوله قطر طبعه الشراكه
بالشراكه السياسيه وفي مجال الدفاع والاب
واا في زراعه الاقتصاديه
والتنمويه كان اليوم الذي له فرصه لمناقشه
قضايا متعدده سواء كان على همم ما يخص
القضايا الاقليميه وايضا التحديات التي
يواجهها العالم اليوم همم كان على
اجدده اجتماعاتنا بناقشه تطورات طبعا ااا
الاتفاق النووي الايراني وايضا التطورات
في الساحه العراقيه
ولبنان وليبيا وايضا القضيه الفلسطينيه
التي تعتبر القضيه المركزيه لدينا